hope for the best prepare for the worst
in the interview the Dalai Lama your
holiness China is growing ever more
powerful in economic ways in political
ways and it is using its power
increasingly to try to isolate you you
being the face of the struggle for
meaningful autonomy for the Tibetans now
what do you think if China had been that
powerful already in 1989 would you have
received a Nobel Prize the Nobel Peace
Prize Oh
firstly I already retired political
responsibility since 2011 completely
retired so your nature of your questions
are more political now however since you
asked it's at that point that question
oh yes people sort of China economically
militarily gaining more strength
meantime noble Chinese very much sort of
support and what our basic right since
you are noticing independence we decided
as early as seven to four 1974 we are
not seeking independence we try to seek
those right which mentioned in the
Constitution
I did one example last I think over four
years
you see we notice many articles in
Chinese language about thousand article
we noticed so all rode by Chinese and
some outside some from within so all
1000 article which we noticed also fully
support about hot material for approach
and very critical about their own combat
policy so these not occurs they could
criticism within the Chinese community
and then on top of that there are and
quite a big number Buddhist population
in China I think about three three years
ago or three four years ago one Chinese
University we carry some survey how many
Buddhists in mainland China they say
about over three hundred millions many
of these Buddhists are educated people
so this naturedly and then nowadays you
see more and more Chinese Buddhists
really showing interest about Tibetan
Buddhism and number of Chinese party
member officials even higher officials
surely interest about but at random
position this is one thing then the
practical level Chinese people change
government very much concerned about
their good image of China the military
economy alone cannot influence or cannot
make constructive sort of contribution
for well adhere the people's world China
need
authority more respect more trust from
outside world the Chinese themselves
also is very much concerned about good
image of China
so therefore the many Chinese told me
they're very to power man power 1.3
billion over over 1.3 billion and I
could have a bar there but lacking moral
sort of authority or moral power so
therefore now for example Xi Jinping
president he's seriously tackling the
world corruption and also recently his
visit in Europe in Paris he openly
stated for Chinese culture but isn't a
very important role so Buddhists should
take more sort of responsibility he
publicly mentioned I think it is
something very unusual communist leader
publicly so diversity praising or
positives or remark about boots so
things are changing but up to now
actually my impression is that the
Chinese leadership is still thinking
that the way to deal with the ethnic
minorities in Tibet or in Xinjiang is
repression and investment that is a
two-fold way yes yes an investment good
but at the same time you see they they
should take seriously what concern about
environment then uses suppression I
think I feel not only Chinese case I
think everywhere suppression
use force often counterproductive
no matter how sincere motivation now era
crisis President Bush I respect him I
love him
his motivation I know very good bring
democracy in Iran but method wrong so
unexpected sort of consequences happen
talking about Iraq this is a question
how to deal with the Islamic state of
the with insurgents of the Islamic state
because you you are loved and respected
the world over because you your approach
is dialogue and tolerance so what do you
do if dialogue fails or if the other
side is not ready for dialogue these are
very very unthinkable sad sort of event
killing human being mercilessly
including children women so this I
believe result also causes basically I
think the era crisis if the American
policy the in order to toppling or
eliminate Saddam Hussein I think more
nonviolent way perhaps to the situation
may be a little better
basically I say it is much better and
safer not used violence but now the
reality is so many people suffer within
the within themselves so well just
remain a City indifferent that also
immoral best thing have to try talk fail
that according the reality accordingly
the circumstances that very difficult to
judge now coming back to to Tibet your
your first response was very optimistic
about prospect yes inning with a Tibetan
situation from the Chinese government
side so are you optimistic yourself to
visit Tibet
again this is judging last over 60 years
watching I usually describe four eras
most of the era ting shopping era a
chance of an era and was it our era
within these four eras many change so
now she you mean I took a recent issue
sort of action seems more realistic as
things having stated seeking truth from
fact I think new leadership
you see follow dad sort of advice
sticking to the firm fact the fact must
be fact not artificial fact so and then
late who I am
exactly it's a followed that so
President Xi Jinping she seems more sore
was the sort of favor or agreement the
would lead as a queen possible approach
so they are cuiabá when he was Lhasa and
early 80 at that time his to the public
speech these things really very
realistic and at the time everybody
you see develop great hope still I
believe if we the women remain with
power more years I think that issue or
just off I believe that so so therefore
the shipping you see seems
that's a more realistic approach so
there is some hope but anyway you see
the it is better remain with hope and
meantime better prepare for worst I over
telling when I met Chinese 1.3 billion
Chinese people have every right to know
the reality in order to implement
seeking total from fat that they should
know the reality
once the 1.3 billion Chinese people
knows the reality they also have the
ability to judge what's right what's
wrong
so censorship is immoral long run
self-destruction thank you very much
your holiness okay thank you very much
good thank you